[Music]
opening exposition covered by rapid-fire
edited sequence of news broadcast cliche
I remember in 2013 a meteor hitting
Russia I also remember this very clip a
bit on YouTube but movie says this
meteor hit Germany these are just in
movie picks a classic world war one
battle site for the alien invasion here
because even aliens know how important
Verdun is when it comes to conquering
Europe the angel of Verdun Emily Blunt
isn't the angel of my pants in this
movie Rita vrataski was able to kill
hundreds of mimics Ruby steals its main
villain name from Horrible 1997 movie
with the same name operation downfall is
going to be the largest mechanized
invasion in the history of mankind and
we're so confident we're broadcasting
the details about it for all humans and
aliens to see maybe for a real soldier
who's been on the frontlines it's
possible to sleep in a drinky ass
helicopter like this but for a cushy PR
guy that is basically a model / actor no
he's not sleeping he's vomiting and
probably bitching about the bumpy ride
look no one loves this movie more than
me but any alien race that would attack
earth with only the capabilities to
fight a lengthy sustained land war
there's a stupid alien race like dumber
than those assholes in science general
I'm an officer in the United States
military you don't even have the
authority I have spoken to your CEO okay
I'll just believe that without a phone
call I wonder why my own CEO didn't tell
me about this what a sandbag job how
hard do you think it would be for me to
convince people to blame you casual
blackmail you will see Kage wake up here
many times throughout this movies
Groundhog Day like narrative but why is
he allowed to sleep here why does no one
put him in a jail cell or a room until
he regains consciousness anything goes
in this military I guess also the
general said this was a PR thing with a
camera crew and I didn't ask her to
sound me I want you to sell the invasion
you ship out to the coast in one hour
the camera crew is standing by
but then after Cruz tries to blackmail
him the general bust is ranked down has
him tased handcuffed and still sends him
to the frontlines without a camera crew
so this one from a PR thing about
selling the war effort to some kind of
twisted punishment that is certainly not
military appropriate even if England and
America have joined forces
how does no-one recognize the one
asshole who's been on TV on practically
every channel as this wars media
strategist so LFO buddies on lockdown no
calls you know this is the equivalent of
kids
being able to get cell phone reception
in a backwoods horror movie it's
actually kind of a silly convenience for
the plot but I'll just go ahead and send
it for the fact that Cage didn't bother
to make a phone call to his CEO earlier
deciding blackmail was his best course
of action says he a deserter and what we
do with deserters who have no talent
outside of advertising is we put them on
the front lines with heavy gun suits and
just laugh while they everything up in
the aliens win because this is
apparently the men of the Nights Watch
from Game of Thrones yes that's correct
even though Rita is a revered soldier
who is kicked all sorts of alien ass and
known as a bitch there's still some
dumbass brave enough to talk right in
front of her also it's pretty amazing
that after a woman beat all the alien
ass inspiring millions of people
especially women the military is still
99% dudes in this movie change actually
tries this sergeant Farell survives this
why doesn't everyone in this army have
one of these amazing slaughter paddles
the hell's she doing fiery crucible in
which the only true heroes are fail
starts this line outside but then waits
20 seconds until they're inside to
finish it despite everything repeating
itself almost exactly Kage still waits
forever to drop during the second time
through the ship explosion maybe the
exosuits can absorb some or even most of
the impact of a phone like this maybe
but even still he's gonna get a
concussion from this kind of bullshit
at the very least right this body is
coming to a jarring stop after moving
super fast so his brain and heart and
spleen and she's gonna be rattling
around to the degree a normal person
would puke and then die right Paige is a
direct descendant of crazy realm from
Friday the 13th Kage clearly
demonstrates he has knowledge of the
future but they ignore it and just tape
his mouth shut because movie needs to be
longer than 30 minutes movie that
conveniently skipped over the 8 or so
hours at night before launch every
previous time through this history we'll
now take advantage of that time for plot
advancement nobody who militaries for
living notices issue also hell he's
running alongside the truck and full
view of everyone behind him and to the
side off camera how is this possibly
safe if telling me there are never any
bullets ricocheting back into these
wide-open firing windows killing these
workers standing here not doing sexy
push-up for no reason is a sin but also
sexy enough to take off asset so move
along nothing to see here no one
understands mimic biology better than
him Wow good thing he's on the same base
as you guys am i right
I sincerely doubt the effectiveness of
hologram presentations but futuristic
movies keep telling me they're gonna be
a thing even though they are objectively
worse at relaying information than any
presentation software that we currently
use this is the brain control small
here's the aliens are all controlled by
one source cliche it's always simple
when it comes to defeating aliens isn't
it and the Omega has the ability control
time whenever an alpha is killed an
automatic response is triggered the
Omega starts the day over again but they
were winning the war is this basically
saying that the Omega will start the day
over again no matter what's happening on
the battlefield
they're killing millions of people in an
ambush and they lose one alpha and it's
like whoops got to start this over again
but if that's true how did you whenever
done we were allowed to win yeah after a
thousand tries apparently if the alien
plan was to allow you to win at Verdun
why did it take you that many tries to
actually win also did it purposely
infect you with its blown to do this or
was it purely by accident because the
alien plan entirely relies on your
ability to adapt otherwise you were
gonna lose and this whole plan goes up
in smoke this thing wants us to believe
we can win it wants us to throw
everything we have into the invasion did
they just get impatient it seems like
the aliens have pretty good control over
the war and nothing was gonna stop them
but they needed a speedy victory I guess
because they have to answer to alien
Congress or something also look I'm all
for the convenience that cage killed the
one in six point one eight million alpha
alien that allows him to control time
but this ridiculous let them win one
battle strategy offers the convenience
that one other person just happened to
be infected by the Alpha and is able to
train cage right now when he would have
otherwise been unable to help himself
seeing you can understand this this is a
perfectly evolved world-conquering
organism that's taken years and still
only basically has control of Europe
it's only vulnerability is humanity so
allergic to earth basically Skinner you
dumbass you rot next to you telling me
you don't know where that slippery son
of bitch went sergeant Farell would be
excellent at cinemasins
oh you mean sex yeah tried it do or do
not hot soldier girl there is no crying
okay
I love this this is another reason why
this movie is so fun I'm taking off a
couple sins here I'm not made of stone
movie that already stated that the Omega
is looking for Tom Cruise and he'll
start getting the visions when the Omega
is getting close to figuring out who and
where he is decides to forget all that
and give him another hundred lives
without the Omega getting any closer to
finding him I go something on my face
maybe the movies saying that cage is
tired of seeing Rita die over and over
and that's why we're in the training
simulation today but we did say that
training was over earlier it's a Tom
Cruise movie so here's that riding a
motorcycle scene you were all clamoring
for you can do this you can keep coming
here every day and I'll train you they
must have figured out how to get into
the training facility by himself without
anyone knowing how did he do this I
don't know I guess I don't have to
remain a mystery literally on a prime
ass piece of coastal French real estate
there was somehow in trailer park
complete with bombed out amusement park
attractions because reasons he
specifically reminded her to disconnect
the trailer but five seconds later she
forgot because hilariousness coincident
only vehicle they really had as an
option just happens to be low on gas
cliche it must be deja vu her Emily
Blunt can actually time travel because
she goes to the exact same house in
which he was staying in looper hey three
movie rips off the guy manipulating the
reliving of one day to gain insight into
a woman ends up creeping outside woman
by knowing too much about them thing
from Groundhog Day as far as you go what
I do he seriously hasn't thought of a
way to keep her from going to the
helicopter after all these times can he
just lead with that up front at the
beginning of the day and say you
constantly put this up by wanting to get
in a helicopter
so put that out of your mind okay even
if he has done that it's unbelievable
she always goes for the helicopter ya
know he's dead they reset what is the
Alpha waiting for I realize they
understand they can't kill him but do
something what the hell is this thing
right for escaping and convenient I type
in white yes and I got fired for it
thank you very much then how the are you
just hanging around at the Maine United
defense military base creating awesome
computer simulations and it's a
transponder you stick it into the Alpha
and it taps into the wavelength
connecting it to the embankment when I
wasn't using this plan in the first
place sounds like some magical ash but
damn how many times that these two died
needlessly before anyone even brought up
this guy with the yellow armband always
recognizes you just keep your head down
stand to my right why doesn't everyone
recognize her their face is plastered
all over the damn world
in fact why do they have to sneak into
any place she's a freaking celebrity I
don't understand
it's the Louvre Omega coincidentally
takes up residence in iconic landmark
and these mimics have an amazing
knowledge of Earth's iconography
listen pal I don't really care what you
think you know about us we just met you
that's correct but despite this
completely healthy skepticism movie will
still let this gonna be talked into it
while we follow him into combat I don't
expect you to follow me I expect you to
follow her cage please the pronoun game
so that Rita can make this dramatic
entrance
also Kate holds us from card until the
very end because it's not like time is
of the essence or anything even in the
midst of an alien war military aerial
ships are allowed to be taken without
notice her objection cage survives this
a minute ago we saw sergeant Farell
giving a speech about giving 100% which
during several of cages lives meant they
were about to get on the ship for the
beach battle during the early morning
daylight hours but here it's completely
dark with no sign of daylight anytime
soon no mimics attack during the
planning and execution of the clear the
path idea any good boys in time guy he
was relatively okay he sacrifices
himself for the group for no real reason
when Kate could die he died pretty much
every time he expected him to now that
he can't die he survived like this in
cage good dying he died pretty much
every time we you saying I already said
this it's probably because the Alpha got
killed and I don't remember saying it
from before the Alpha has to know at
this point that the humans can no longer
reset the day
so is he waiting for movie rips off that
reveals the Grenade pins thing from Lian
aka the professional but really Lian so
you're telling me he ended the war by
killing the Omega but still reset the
day killing the Alpha as well so he
could let the girl live and be her
boyfriend man I guess the power of
boners really is stronger also how did
he kill the Omega and inherit the alphas
ability reset the day without also
resetting the Omega being a lot he wakes
up a day earlier in the news is talking
about a mysterious explosion the night
before this which definitely does not
compute since he and the gang raid the
Louvre later tonight to caused that
explosion but whatever it gets the girl
I think sexy push-up girl is always
doing 60 push-ups what do you want good
for you Doug Liman Bravo sir
[Music]
so let strategize not you
the horses have told us that the
collisions are preparing for enraging so
we must new talking each retiring has a
specific code name and mission you you
do what you do no cuts no butts no
coconuts
this is puppet dragon
we can rebuild him we have the
technology use the Force
have you done that you got three pints
of grammar anybody I immediately regret
this decision
[Music]
this is the end
we've been through worse I've you and
Jack an effective team
[Music]
the only thing I'd do differently if I
were Tom Cruise's character and age of
tomorrow is I change up my nature box
snack order every time I reset the day
that way I could eventually through all
the dying and waking back up inside to
try every single nature box snack
available they have tons of snacks how
many it's not actually a very high
number five that's a computer key not a
number it's over we're getting much
closer that's for sure I think we're
maybe getting sidetracked okay you know
let's just say however many varieties of
snacks you hope they have they have more
well then anyway if you go to
naturebox.com/tyler Messines our friends
at nature box will give you a free
sampler box just for signing up free as
in less than costing something no
dollars just snacks so get thee to
naturebox.com/tyler cinemasins and show
your thanks to them for supporting our
channel it's a pretty huge sacrifice to
ask you to accept three delicious snacks
but we're confident some of you will
have the courage or the outright hunger
to help us get it done now if you don't
mind I'm gonna reset the day again I'm
thinking peanut butter and jelly granola
this time